tenemos aquí tres figuras y tenemos tres
números entonces tenemos una estrella un
cuadrado y un triángulo y el número
representa cuántas de esas figuras
tenemos tenemos cinco estrellas tres
cuadrados y seis triángulos entonces
queremos saber cuantas figuras tenemos
en total que se te ocurre si lo que
piensas es sumar todos estos números
estás en lo correcto eso eso nos indica
cuántas figuras tenemos en total
entonces sumamos estos tres números
tenemos cinco estrellas más tres
cuadrados más seis triángulos y podemos
sumar estos dos números primero tenemos
53 eso es igual a 8 y al 8 le podemos
sumar 6 entonces 86 eso cuánto es sino
sabes es de las cosas que tal vez te
sirva a tener en la cabeza siempre
recuerda que 86 eso es igual
14 solamente tiene una en la mente
siempre entonces 86 es igual a 14 y así
que esto también es igual a 14
ahora el orden no importa por ejemplo
podría yo haber sumado 3 más 6 primero
entonces bueno hagamos otra vez esta
suma pero en diferente orden pongo aquí
5 5 estrellas más 3 cuadrados más 6
triángulos y ahora voy a sumar primero
el 3 y el 6 3 + 6 eso es igual a 9 a 9
le vamos a sumar 5 entonces 59 eso
también si no sabéis cuánto es eso
recuerda lo 59 es igual a 14 ahora si
aún no te queda claro por ejemplo puedes
tomar 5 frijoles y sumarle otros 9
frijoles eso también te daría 14
frijoles ahora como te digo el orden no
importa en la suma yo pude haber sumado
5 y 6 eso es igual a 11 y después a 11
sumarle 3 también es 14